breakups for no reason but I love yous
are in season whoa
and it all happened over five freakin
hours intelligence was an announcement
of a new bachelor whoa it's time for
roses and Rosie we are here to recap
bachelor in paradise and of course talk
about our feelings on our new bachelors
well earlier that's golden Underwood
everybody do you want to see cool to
wear more hoodies on the bachelor
I would guess not but let me know
because I have a lot of questions about
why some people broke up with some
people let's dive in this week I've got
a red drink to go along with our rose
red motif and it's no sangria
made for me by our own YouTube
specialist Brian Moran oh hi Brian shout
out to you from a recipe he got right
from Spain
hey guys five hours of television this
week what am i back on the winter games
days I like a man
yeah what else you look for in a man I
don't know what happened in the first 10
minutes of episode 1 from Monday night
because I don't know I was eating Oreos
and I wasn't paying attention I had 5
get hours to get through you guys ok mmm
so drink every time you've been fast
forwarded a little bit be honest it's
fine we still love the show but be
honest we're not watching every minute
of this Eric Angela Fame anyway things
get good
Colton breaks up with TIA thank you look
at you 100% certainty and say that
I try here and you know he says the Tia
deserves better
I think being Colton are on the same
page Tia again says she and Colton are
on the same page but tea is the most
consistent relationship you have on this
show is the one you have with that black
swimsuit honestly can they stop wearing
these things maybe it's editing but
they're just wearing these outfits so
much then again when going left you only
had a backpack so you know it's right
you can't pack sleeves if you want to
fit everything in the backpack it's too
much so Colton says th she doesn't
deserve somebody who's now all-in I want
to know what you guys thought of
Colton's reasoning on why he broke up
with Tia it felt out of nowhere didn't
it it was like we saw so much Colton and
Tia for most of the season and then they
disappeared and now he's breaking up
with her and why he just says he can't
give her what she needs
well that's worrisome Colton because
you're about to go on a show where
you're gonna have to give a lot of women
what they need and your future wife may
be what she needs
so I don't know I talked to tea about it
and interviews up Aditi online calm
she spoiler alert doesn't think Colton's
ready to be the bachelor
Oh harsh do you guys think Coulomb is
ready to be the bachelor tell me if he
had said look we gave this a shot and we
don't have enough in common okay but it
was weird to me what he said he couldn't
give her what she needed but I gotta
give Tia credit because man she gave
herself what she needed she took this
breakup pretty well pretty low not mad
crying a lot of Tears don't drink every
time somebody crying this season was too
episode oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
really figure yourself out that's T is
saying you're probably gonna be the
bachelor I think she knew it then figure
yourself out do you guys think because a
lot of people have been asking me this
that Colton broke up with Tia in part
because or perhaps entirely because he
knew he could be the bachelor let me
know I have to say I didn't think that
relationship is gonna work out I didn't
I felt like they had this brief
connection then they wanted to explore
it and it had been blowing up to more
than it was and I didn't think okay
anyway oh my god but then amongst the
darkness every once in a while we get
the sliver of light that is Jordan get
out of here haven't seen calling him Tia
for a while are you and Jenna is
freaking out about all the breakups that
are happening she's spiraling I think
Jenna's an emotional person I still like
her a lot I'm just saying and Jordan
Jordan grounds her on that daybed in the
sweetest way he is just comforting her
telling her everything she needs to hear
saying that he is not she's not but he
likes her so much I love Jordan what did
you guys think of this moment between
Jordan and Jenna were you just
salivating over it cheers to frickin
Jordan also very excited to not see
Jenna's butt being covered by a black
box we have confirmed we've confirmed
here on ET Jenna has a but Jenna has a
but confirmed excellent okay Erik gets
back from his day with Cassie because
they did that and I don't
one of the strongest couples here do not
drink every time Eric made no sense at
all
he tells Angela well he was all in with
her and she wasn't you've been saying
all these things to me and she was like
no no I was totally all-in and I just
felt that Eric was kind of switching and
trying to put the blame on Angela and it
didn't feel fair to me what do you guys
think did you understand
Erin's and side with him or did you feel
like Angela was totally in the right
here let me know oh yeah and then
Shoshanna Shu her name is Shu is here
and 67 million more women arrived
christen aka scallops from last season
and you know what is mind-boggling is
that no matter how many women arrive
camille or column or cullen or whatever
that vampire's name is he's still so
dead behind the eyes and it's almost as
though he is mesmerizing these women
because Shu is into him and Annalise
says she doesn't want to be a stage five
clinger but boo boo is looking all over
for you I gotta get out of here pronto I
got a stage five clinger she's like
what's her name in wedding crashers all
the way I just feel like my heart it's
gonna be broken and I know it's gonna be
a different kind of pain Annelise flips
out you guys she freakin loses it all
week long this week she's crying
non-stop she's saying she sees
everything with Camille whatever his
name is and she's just losing it she's
not making sense
god help us please come back to Annalise
paradise is not ready for what Annalise
will do to this place and then Ashley
and Jared arrived and I want to take a
moment for this comedy Ashley hi Kennedy
I love her is walking on the beach to be
proposed to in stilettos
did everybody zoom in into the sand do
not drink every time her heels sunk into
the sand hmm babe take your shoes off
you've been here before
wear a wedge come on no but the proposal
was really sweet and I'm really happy
for Jared and Ashley and we have an
interview up with them a detail line
they're coming that's great
she's all of a sudden with a guy the day
after me and now they're engaged it's
like was I just a pawn oh but don't
drink everytime you Kevin against if
something shady but Ashley this season
he says he wonders if he was a pawn in
her scheme I don't think he was a pawn
in her scheme what do you guys think I
think that he got caught up in her love
story which was always gonna end in
Jared but let me know you think and then
Kevin and Astrid say I love you so who
cares drink every time somebody says I
love you what's happening it was great
in five hours of TV Annalise says we're
literally like the same person she and
Edward Cullen are the same person
no you're not and then John and Olivia
are eating something and I can't tell
what they're eating drink every time you
can't tell people are eating on the show
the food we've given more shots of the
food I don't know what they're eating
mmm oh god Chris Harrison asked Annalise
how she's doing and she says good you're
not doing good babe own it around this
time I was starting to zone out because
you know for whatever reason this was a
three hour episode and then it's the
rose ceremony and Eric gave his rose to
Cassandra what I'm just whatever okay
and we're playing a really fun little
game of fill in the blank on the screen
here where he's saying that the
you-know-what is tough but it's like why
did they give us that line on the screen
it's like mad libs the meat was tough
the humidity was tough the sand was
tough to walk in for Ashley I anyway we
end the episode with a lot going on
Kristin seems to have some kind of heat
stroke moment Chelsea's having a panic
attack oh my god so many deep
frightening breaths and then it all
wraps up with Chris Harrison's voice
saying tomorrow night on The Bachelor so
tomorrow night on The Bachelor but
tonight Tuesday night's episode anyway
let's all go to the lobby to get
ourselves a treat Evan and Carly and
Jade and Tanner come with their cute
little kids to auction off a date and I
really love that Jordan and Jenna just
owned that like they wanted to get the
[ __ ] off this beach that's why they
wanted the date they're like we gotta
get out of here the whole these people
are trapped in this tiny beach you guys
I've been there the beach is not that
big Astrid and Kevin want the date
everybody's having to fight for the date
and they see if they've got a 12-month
plan for their relationship I don't have
a 12-month plan for my skin monthly
bills that I have to pay
which I should why don't I have more
things on auto pay so many late fees
okay Colin tells Annalise to slow down
that's how he fights for the date
they're not gonna get that it mm-hmm
Kendall Jo make your way over to the
baby pop and start that baby and then we
get another amazing shine of light
through the darkness with grocery store
Joe him and Kendall are watching these
kids and he says I like it
I can see Kendall be a good mother one
day and they are a nice break from the
insanity Joe and Kendall and Jordan and
Jenna yes all right mr. he's across the
radar it was so good it's just season um
guys what does the Emily's talking about
I don't know anymore you move at a
certain pace I move in a certain phase
and I feel like like we didn't establish
no type of French it was just we just
went on a date what our caste and Eric
talking about this conversation about
how their friends couldn't be more
painful I do not know what Eric is
saying it is very weird that's what I
wrote down that's what I wrote down
did you guys know what Eric was talking
about and he seemed to be blaming Cassie
as though she didn't understand him I
didn't understand him did you who did
anyone relationship at all
he then says something about how he
wants a relationship but he's not ready
I don't think he's ready and I don't
think he knows what he wants really hit
me hard you did that I don't know so
Eric chooses to go home and that's all
well and good because it should okay bye
don't drink every time something didn't
make sense so we're still on this shoe
Cullen
Annelise thing although it really
cracked me up that shoe keeps calling
analyse the blonde girl because your
name is shoe who are you to talk and
everyone's been entranced by calling the
vampire and Jordan from New Zealand is
here forgot about him he's the real deal
just says that he needs a rose so he's
gonna flirt with you and I appreciate
his honesty Chris and Crystal's say
they're in love drink every time so he
says they're in love
[Music]
what is that you guys so much TV I just
can't see it we're getting between us I
just don't feel that with my heart
I hope you have not been drinking every
time shoe directly denies what Cullen is
saying it's like he's telling her I'm
not into you and she's like I think you
are thank you all that you tell me the
truth I don't know you don't have a
reasonable idea anyway oh my god diggie
is here new people I'm exhausted no more
new people the finale is next week how
am I gonna get through I'm out I'm out
oh oh
JC thank you thank you the lifeblood and
reinforcements I need it okay thank you
more stuff happens with shoe jordan is
like it hasn't worked out for you but
I've had somebody cool and she says
she's a witch
and he says well that's a stumble and
then the episodes over honestly guys it
was getting tiring also if anyone was
confused by the promo a little bit the
promo for the next week's finale used
footage from what I believe to have been
the bachelor Winter Games tell off
because no that was not new footage so
don't be confused I was at the tell-all
taping and that was not footage from the
tell-all taping so we're gonna see it
all next week next week is the finale
and the tell-all and it's all gonna be
great and I am so excited actually for
where we're at with some of these
couples that's why it was feeling weird
to me to have like Jordan and diggie and
these new people come in at this point
because it just feels so late to the
game and it feels disingenuous like
Kevin and Astor saying I love you Chris
and crystal Jordan and Jenna are talking
about having kids Joe and Kendall are
really into each other and I believe all
these couples I think they are genuinely
into each other so I'm not here for the
new people at this point what did you
guys think were those new people too
little too late and should we just focus
on the couple's now and
here's your paper a couple I must
address the dog loving football playing
elephant in the room Colton Underwood is
our new bachelor everybody here are my
thoughts and I want yours
do you like the choice of Colton as the
new bachelor I've talked to this through
with some of you guys on Instagram
already and feel free to message me
anytime if you haven't I think that
Colton will make for some good TV
he hath proven it time and time again on
The Bachelor wrecked on the Mentos all
special mere hours before the
announcement during a dramatic
tear-filled episode of bachelor in
paradise maybe you've heard of it he's
gonna be good TV I also understand that
he's young and understand that he's just
been in relationships but hey Becca was
engaged to Ari not long before she got
engaged to Garrett and he might be young
but look guys I'm not here thinking of
The Bachelor as a way to find definitive
marriage anymore I'm just not we can't
do that the only bachelor to ever marry
his final pick is Sean Lowe that's one
out of like 25ish so let's just put that
aside he's here to find a relationship
he might find one I'm in I just want to
watch the show so tell me what you think
I also think this season is a little
different because last year it felt very
he-who-must-not-be-named
versus our beloved Peter but this felt
like we had a couple good choices at the
end it didn't feel like one was entirely
pitted against the other Blake would
have been great Jason would have been
great
I think Colton will be great so I'm here
for it and I want to know what you guys
think and next week is the bachelor in
paradise finale and then we've got such
a long break between this and bachelor
I'll miss you guys so much but got some
stuff in the works so JC and I love you
and that's it I'm gonna go take a
ten hour nap by E did you guys think
did everyone just hear JC's phone off
it's okay you still get a rose